viele Wolken geht die über dem Autoland
Deutschland aufziehen lange war es
führend in der Welt Autos made in
Germany standen für Innovation und
Qualität doch plötzlich stottert der
Motor beim Umstieg aufs E-Auto drohen
die deutschen den Anschluss zu verlieren
es sind die Chinesen die gerade mit
Macht auf den Markt in Europa drängen
und jetzt brennt es sogar das Dach steht
in Flammen warnte wörtlich thomas
Schäfer der Markenchef von VW angesichts
einbrechender Auftragszahlen in einer
Brandrede Anfang der Woche verschlafen
die deutschen Autobauer die Zukunft und
muss am Ende die Politik eingreifen um
den Absturz einer Schlüsselindustrie zu
stoppen an der hunderttausende Jobs
hängen das ist unser Thema heute und das
sind meine Gäste
ich begrüße Sonja Alvares
stellvertretende Leiterin des
Hauptstadtbüros der Wirtschaftswoche ich
freue mich dass Nadine Lindner in der
Runde ist Korrespondentin beim
Deutschlandfunk und Deutschlandradio in
Berlin ich begrüße Holger Appel
Ressortleiter Technik und Motor bei der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen und ich freue
mich auf Christina Kunkel die für die
Wirtschaftsredaktion der Süddeutschen
Zeitung über Mobilität berichtet und
noch ein Hinweis für Sie liebe Zuschauer
wir streamen diese Sendung wie immer
live in den sozialen Netzwerken und
freuen uns auch auf ihre Meinung und
Ihre Fragen zu unserem Thema
Frau Alvarez wenn wir auf die deutsche
Autoindustrie und das Thema e-Mobilität
gucken dann fällt ja auf dass die
Deutschen nach wie vor sehr
zurückhaltend sind im eigenen Land vor
allen Dingen Ende 22 war nur gut eine
Millionen reine E-Autos zugelassen das
ungefähr einen Anteil von 2% am gesamten
Pkw-Bestand warum zögern die Deutschen
so naja erstmal muss man sagen dass
Deutschland ja wirklich ein Autoland ist
1886 ist hier das Automobil erfunden
worden Deutschland hatte jahrelang die
Technologieführerschaft und mit dem
Auslaufen des Verbrenners ändert sich
das jetzt eben und ähm der Automarkt
will elektrifiziert die deutschen
Hersteller muss man wirklich sagen guten
Morgen haben sie ihren Tempomat auf
Tiefschlaf gestellt oder wie konnte es
sein dass sie den diesen Anschluss
verpasst haben das sehen wir ja in den
aktuellen Zulassungszahlen Tesla führt
aktuell im in den Zulassungszahlen und
hat die deutsche Automobilindustrie auf
die hinteren Plätze verwiesen bleibt mir
noch mal beim zögern der deutschen also
der Autofahrer im eigenen Land Herr
Appel die Bundesregierung hat das Ziel
von 15 Millionen Zulassungen von E-Autos
bis 2035 ist 2030 sogar ausgegeben wie
realistisch ist dieses Ziel angesichts
der Entwicklung die ja wirklich noch
sehr sehr mühsam und sehr ist ich dachte
eigentlich wir sind noch bei 10
Millionen aber die erreichen wir ja auch
nicht
also wenn wir jetzt eine Million haben
müssen wir in sechs Jahren wie viel die
anderen 9 oder wie noch hinkriegen das
werden wir nicht schaffen wir sind jetzt
bei einem Marktanteil trotz des Booms
der noch rüber gekommen ist in das Jahr
bei 15 % und ich glaube da werden wir in
etwa verharren das ist das Elektroauto
ist heute ein Auto was bei den wohl
haben den vorstädtern angekommen ist und
es kommt nicht in die breite Bevölkerung
rein und da sehe ich ein großes Problem
weil es nämlich den Leuten im Moment
noch stand heute mehr nimmt als es ihnen
gibt und deswegen werden wir da
glaube ich ein Fahrt wiederfinden müssen
Rück zur technologieoffenheit die leider
mit dem Verbrenner Verbot
beerdigt worden Frau Kunkel bleiben wir
noch mal beim zögern der Autokäufer in
Deutschland im eigenen Land
er apple hat gesagt es ist im Moment das
Elektroauto das Modell der besser
verdienenden was ist das Problem also
warum gibt es keine günstigen
Einstiegsmodelle und welche Rolle spielt
es dass die Kaufprämie für E-Autos in
diesem Jahr noch mal zurückgenommen
wurde also der Preis ist natürlich ein
großes Problem stimmt mich total zu also
vor allem wenn man sagt man guckt auf
den Gebrauchtwagenmarkt also Menschen
viele Menschen kaufen sich ja kein neues
Auto die Neuwagen Zulassungen sind ja
hauptsächlich von von Dienstwagen
getrieben und wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
gucken auf den Gebrauchtwagenmarkt dann
ist es einfach so dass jetzt jemand der
sonst sich ja Jahreswagen zwei drei
Jahre altes Auto gekauft hatte das ja
20.000 € vielleicht gekostet hat oder
15.000 der findet eben heutzutage im
Elektromarkt einfach nichts sehr wenig
und eben dazu klar kommt die die
Ladeinfrastruktur die immer noch nicht
überall so gut ist dass man sagen kann
ich weiß jetzt genau wo kann ich mein
Auto laden es kostet mich so und so viel
man muss einfach unterscheiden wo wo
wohne ich und was habe ich für
Möglichkeiten und auch welche welche
preismöglichkeiten habe ich Frau Lindner
auch ihre wichtigste Erkenntnis für die
Grünen die die Deutschen noch zögern
lassen woran liegt dass die Lade
Infrastruktur zum Beispiel praktische
Probleme hat das da alles also und ich
würde eigentlich gerne die Liste die wir
hier schon angefangen haben mit es ist
eigentlich zu teuer für viele
Bevölkerungsgruppen ja das ist natürlich
eine Frage des Einstiegspreises bei
E-Autos kommt es dann natürlich auch den
Betrieb an auf die Kosten für das Laden
was wiederum natürlich halt auch durch
viele Faktoren eigene Wohnsituationen
habe ich zum Beispiel eine Solaranlage
auf dem Dach natürlich noch mit geprägt
wird es gibt aber auch und das geht ein
bisschen glaube ich in die Richtung der
beschrieben hat es gibt auch
letztendlich Zweifel an der Technologie
also es gibt eine ganz interessante
Umfrage des Instituts Allensbach jetzt
aus dem Mai diese überschrieben mit den
Worten lost in Transformation 60 Prozent
der dort Befragten haben gesagt sie
haben Zweifel an der
Umweltfreundlichkeit die wiederum durch
andere Studienjahr belegt ist im
Gesamtleben eines E-Autos dazu kommt das
klang eben schon an mangelnde
Verfügbarkeit gerade von E-Autos der
deutschen Herstellers dort teilweise
ewig bis dieses Auto da ist und ich
glaube auch dass das förderregime die
Veränderungen dort die gekommen sind die
aber noch kommen vor allem glaube ich
auch im dienstwagenbereich dem Ganzen
dann nicht dienlich sein werden also wir
stellen gerade hier fest in der ersten
Runde wir haben einen ganzen Straußen
den ganzen eine ganze Sammlung von
Gründen die die Leute zögern lassen sich
fürs Auto zu entscheiden wer ist denn
der Hauptverantwortliche dafür hat Apple
ist es vorwiegend die Autoindustrie
selbst oder ist es die Politik
es ist erstmal die Technik sie haben sie
können mit dem Elektroauto nicht das
Gleiche tun was sie bis jetzt mit einem
Auto mit Verbrennungsmotor tun können es
hat den großen Vorteil der lokalen
Emissionsfreiheit und des leise des
leisen Fahrens in der Stadt und es hat
den großen Nachteil dass sie eben nicht
weiter als 250 300 km fahren kann nicht
schneller als 120 oder 130 sonst ist der
Akku schnell leer und sie haben heute
keine keine brauchbaren Autos unter 35
40.000 €
. das sind so große Restriktionen dass
die Technik aus heutigem Stand
unterlegen ist dem was die Menschen
gewohnt sind ob das in zehn Jahren noch
so ist weiß ich nicht aber deswegen
hätte ich halt gerne dass wir sagen gut
da geben wir doch der der Industrie die
Möglichkeit sich zu entwickeln das heißt
wir kommen sicherlich noch drauf sei es
Wasserstoff Salz irgendwas was jemand
noch erfindet es ist immer alles so lang
unmöglich bis es einer Macht und da
hätte ich gerne eine
technologieoffenheit und nicht dass die
Politik hier schon Lösungen vorgibt ich
finde das ist nicht ihre Aufgabe sie
soll Leitplanken setzen aber nicht
Lösung ich höre
muss ich direkt mal wieder sprechen also
diese diese Angaben von ein Auto kommt
nur 250 Kilometer nur 300 km weit das
ist ja längst überholt also das stimmt
stimmt ja bei vielen Autos nicht also
ein Tesla kommt locker weiter als 350
Kilometer zum Beispiel 120 fährt ja aber
das ist auch wieder bei der Frage wie
weit fahren denn die Menschen am Tag
also man muss ja auch mal realistisch
gucken was sind denn die Wege die
Menschen zurücklegen pro Tag und da gibt
es nur eine sehr kleine Gruppe die an
einem Tag jetzt mehr als 300 km fährt
z.B ein Auto steht 23 Stunden am Tag rum
wo das Auto steht kann es geladen werden
also von daher ist ja da auch die Frage
müssen wir uns nicht darum kümmern dass
das Auto überall da geladen werden kann
wo ist sowieso steht und wir reden
wirklich nur noch von einem ganz ganz
kleinen Teil an Menschen die diese diese
Reichweiten Angst wirklich vielleicht zu
Recht haben aber ansonsten die meisten
Wege die die Menschen zurücklegen in
einer Woche da reicht das für die locker
aus wenn die einmal Laden also
[Musik]
natürlich immer schwierig sozusagen mit
Statistiken den
Empfindungen oder auch dieser
reichweitenangst entgegenzuwirken aber
eigentlich weiß man aus den
mobilitätserhebungen dass die Menschen
im Schnitt 40 Kilometer am Tag fahren
das wird zur Arbeit gefahren das sind im
Schnitt das muss jetzt nicht für jeden
einzelnen zutreffen sind 16 km
Arbeitsweg hin und zurück und dann
natürlich noch die Wege kita-schule
Einkaufen Freizeitgestaltung etc pp das
sind halt aber Wege die man mit bislang
jedem verfügbaren Elektroauto dann auch
zurücklegen kann aber natürlich gibt es
auch andere
Nutzungsvarianten dann vielleicht nur
punktuell zwei dreimal im Jahr wo man
längere Strecken fahren möchte und ich
glaube da wird es dann natürlich auch zu
einer gewissen
Umorientierung und das ist ja auch das
was ihr Autofahrer berichten auch zum zu
einer Umstellung von
Nutzungsgewohnheiten kommen müssen nur
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass es doch
in den Alltag dann auch reinpasst wenn
man sich jetzt an diesen Zahlen
orientiert Frau Alvarez wie groß sind
die technischen Probleme und Mängel in
ihren Augen ja der Kollege hat ja gerade
schon das schöne Schlagwort
technologieoffenheit angesprochen und
wissen Sie wer sich am allermeisten über
diese Debatte freut das ist vielleicht
abgesehen davon von Volker Wissing die
Konkurrenz ja also während wir hier über
ein ja Zaubertrank schwadronieren werden
anders wo die Zukunftsmärkte erobert und
der Zukunftsmarkt ist eben ganz klar die
E-Mobilität und wie berichten jetzt in
der aktuellen Ausgabe der
Wirtschaftswoche auch über ein Treffen
im Kanzleramt das ist Mitte Mai gegeben
hat da wurden dann am aller engsten
Kreis haben sich die drei Autos die
ausgetroffen mit Olaf Scholz und nach
allem was uns übermittelt worden ist was
dann nicht so dass die jetzt auf Knien
den Kanzler angefleht haben er möchte
bitte das Verbrenner Verbot rückgängig
machen sondern die Autoindustrie selbst
ist ja schon tatsächlich weiter und
fokussiert sich auf die die Immobilität
hat aber natürlich erhebliche Baustellen
der aufzuholen im Vergleich zu der
Konkurrenz aus Amerika und künftig auch
aus China das ist spannend vielleicht
mal bei dem Punkt und bei diesen
Gesprächen im Kanzleramt bleiben wir
waren nicht dabei aber wir können ja
schon beurteilen wie die Autoindustrie
gerade da steht wie schlecht ist es denn
aktuell um die bestellt und die deutsche
Industrie
also erstmal ist es doch so egal wo man
auf der Welt hinkommt die Leute sagen
ich möchte irgendwann mal Audi BMW
Mercedes oder Porsche fahren also so
schlecht kannst um sie noch nicht stehen
und Herrn Wissing bin ich übrigens sehr
dankbar dass der einzige der den Mumm
hatte da eine Öffnungsklausel hinein zu
verhandeln zwar auf der letzten Rille
das kann man wohl schon sagen hätten sie
vielleicht ein bisschen vorher tun
können die FDP aber er hat es immerhin
gemacht und deswegen kriegen wir eine
Revision 2026 oder sowas in der EU
Kommission da kann man nur hoffen dass
sich die technologieoffenheit wieder
durchsetzt und das in eröffnungsklausel
geben wird wird immer mans glaube ich
verantworten müssen da wäre die wäre die
Adresse ansonsten ist hier deutsche
Autoindustrie ja schon x-mal tot geredet
worden ja als die und sind die sind
irgendwann die Japaner gekommen sind die
Koreaner gekommen jetzt kommen die
Chinesen ich glaube dass wir darauf auch
gute Antworten finden werden und
vertraue da dem Ideenreichtum der
Unternehmer und der Ingenieur teilen Sie
den Optimismus
wie sehen sie den Zustand der deutschen
Autoindustrie gerade im Moment also ich
teile den Optimismus insofern dass ich
schon auch glaube dass die dass die
deutschen Autobauer sehr viel getan
haben in den letzten Jahren also dass
dieser Weckruf auf jeden Fall da war
aber der der Weg ist lang und ich glaube
auch dass es kurzfristig oder
mittelfristig erstmal dazu führen wird
dass wir geringere Gewinne einfach sehen
werden also dass da jetzt nicht mehr
diese Rekordzahlen da sein werden wie
sie in den letzten Jahren da waren und
das davon muss man ausgehen weil es eben
einfach noch ja vielleicht zwei drei
Jahre dauern wird bis eben die Modelle
kommen die dann für die Menschen er
schwingen sind aber mit denen auch die
Autohersteller Geld verdienen weil das
ist ja das große Problem im Moment ist
nicht mehr die Technik das Problem
deutsche Hersteller bauen super tolle
Elektroautos aber gerade wenn man VW
anschaut sie kriegen sie halt einfach
nicht zu guten Preisen verkauft dass sie
auch selber noch dran verdienen und das
ist ja das Problem in dem gerade eben
der Massenmarkt steckt im Vergleich zu
Tesla oder zu den chinesischen
Herstellern ich nehme noch zwei User
Twitter mit reinen da fragt einer warum
müssen wir hier immer noch über
Fahrzeuge und verbrennermotoren
diskutieren während die Welt längst
elektrisch fährt und jemand anders sagt
wieso hat die deutsche Autoindustrie
weiter auf den Verbrenner gesetzt obwohl
doch schon seit zehn Jahren klar ist
dass sich der E-Motor durchsetzen wird
Frau Alpha ist ja ich glaube dass
womöglich eine ja ich weiß nicht ob man
es auch ganz nennen kann aber ich glaube
die deutsche Automobilindustrie hat sich
natürlich sehr sicher gefühlt also
wenn wir mal schauen 2019 hat Volkswagen
sein erstes vollelektrisches Auto mit
dem id.3 produziert
da hat Tesla schon eine Millionen
Fahrzeuge auf dem Markt gehabt ja und
heute ist Tesla nicht nur dass ihm auch
in Deutschland meistverkaufte.de Auto
sondern ist an der Börse auch so viel
wert wie alle drei deutschen
Automobilkonzerne zusammen das ist schon
für den Standort Deutschland und die
Automobilindustrie ist hier der
wichtigste Industriezweig eine
dramatische Entwicklung die deutsche
Autoindustrie steht war also
wahrscheinlich einer der größten
Wandlungsprozesse ihrer Geschichte und
um es auch noch mal zu sagen in Zahlen
rund 780.000 Beschäftigte arbeiten
unmittelbar in der Autoindustrie und
wenn man Zulieferbetriebe klein und
große noch dazu nimmt dann sind das
insgesamt etwa zwei Millionen Menschen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
welche Folgen drohen volkswirtschaftlich
werden die Autobauer den Anschluss
verlieren naja das
sozusagen also die Gefahr ist da und ich
glaube es ist gut dass sie an der Stelle
die Zulieferindustrie noch mal
angesprochen haben die ja durchaus
divers ist wenn wir über
Automobilindustrie reden denken wir
eigentlich an die drei großen Hersteller
das ist Mercedes Volkswagen BMW man
konnte für das Jahr 2022 hohe Gewinne
sehen bei allen drei Herstellern und auf
der anderen Seite ich finde das ja
wirklich erstaunlich wenn man sich
Volkswagen anschaut alleine in der
Kernmarke letztes Jahr 2,6 Milliarden
Euro gewinnen auf der anderen Seite dann
im Sommer 2023 die Aussage der Dachstuhl
das Dach steht in Flammen das Haus steht
eigentlich schon fast in Flammen ich
glaube daran sieht man die dieses
voranschreiten in eine ungewisse und
ruckelige Zukunft und meiner Ansicht
nach wird aber die Situation für die
Kleinen im Moment noch auf die
verbrennermotoren spezialisierten
Zulieferer die ja auch regional
verankert sind Rheinland-Pfalz Saarland
dort für diese Region wird schwierig
werden man nach dem was ich so sehe hat
man das auch schon in der letzten
Legislaturperiode zumindest politisch
erkannt aber die Mechanismen die man
bislang dafür so ins Werke gesetzt hat
kann glaube ich diese Marktveränderungen
noch weder kompensieren noch aufhalten
also ich glaube da lohnt es sich auch
wirklich auch noch ein Fokus
draufzulegen dass die großen Hersteller
mit ihrer Ingenieurskunst auch mit einem
dicken gewinnpolster dadurch kommen und
bestehen bleiben werden sich wandeln
werden das glaube ich schon aber die die
Automobilindustrie ist ja noch mehr also
die die Frage während die ganze Welt
elektrisch fertig wisst ihr ja nicht wer
in der ganzen Welt elektrisch fährt
soweit ich weiß sind ziemlich viele
Regionen noch mit Verbrennungsmotoren
unterwegs und hier ja auch 85% des
Marktes also klar bauen Sie diese
Fahrzeuge die die Menschen kaufen finde
ich völlig logisch und ist auch richtig
sie haben gute Absatzzahlen hohe Gewinne
ausgewiesen und was Tesla macht ist eine
tolle Sache die sind die haben sich
einen Fanclub erarbeitet haben auch ein
gutes Elektroauto kein gutes Auto aber
ein gutes Elektroauto und haben das wenn
es soweit ich das sehe ohne Subventionen
gemacht und haben sogar eine Ansiedlung
sich in Deutschland getraut was ich euch
großen Respekt vor habe das Auto hätte
natürlich das wäre schon gut gewesen das
wäre von dem deutschen Hersteller
gekommen aber nun befeuert halt der
Wettbewerb das Geschäft finde ich super
das Tesla da ist und die Deutschen
werden Ihre Antworten finden wäre super
gewesen wenn Deutschland dieses Auto
geliefert hätte sagen Sie also das ist
richtig im Kopf hat als VW das erste
reine Elektroauto vom Band hat rollen
lassen da hatte Tesla schon eine halbe
Million PKW verkauft oder ja und das
erste Elektroauto von VW war und ich gut
gemacht ja aber die sind ja nicht die
einzigen es gibt ja noch ein paar andere
und es gibt zum Beispiel in Stuttgart
ein ziemlich gutes Elektroauto aber das
sind natürlich wieder ein Preisregionen
die die meisten Menschen sich nicht
leisten können und da haben wir ja mal
angefangen kriegen wir die Breite der
Bevölkerung und die kriegen wir halt bis
jetzt nicht
gerade sagt
dass
es ist tatsächlich so dass die Welt oder
viele wichtige Auto merke künftig
elektrisch fahren werden wenn wir mal
auf den wichtigsten Automarkt der Welt
blicken das ist nämlich China dort wird
erwartet dass künftig jedes zweite neu
zugelassene Auto dann eben ein
E-Auto ist und da ist es leider so dass
Volkswagen da auf die hinteren Plätze
verwiesen wird jetzt unter den zehn
meistverkauften Autos in China wenn sich
kein einziges deutsches Auto ja und
dann geht da in die in die Nische
verdrängt ja hat noch einen Marktanteil
bei den Autos von 2,9 Prozent und das
ist natürlich angesichts der großen
Gewinne die Volkswagen dort bisher
gemacht hat und auch seit den 80er
Jahren tatsächlich Marktführer war eine
ja dramatische Entwicklung ja lassen Sie
uns das mal machen lassen uns mal den
Blick öffnen und auf die Konkurrenz
gucken weltweit sie haben ja schon
drüber gesprochen also wenn wir da mal
schauen internationale e-autohersteller
wie Tesla und b.i.d das sind die
Chinesen bildet ja und dreams ist die
Abkürzung für wie weit die haben die
traditionelle deutsche Autoindustrie in
Sachen E-Mobilität ja längst abgehängt
Tesla war 22 2022 mit dem Modell white
das meist verkaufte E-Auto in
Deutschland volkswagensidee 4 folgte
erst auf Platz 4 warum verkauft sich die
Konkurrenz so viel besser ja weil Tesla
immer noch das beste Preis
Leistungsverhältnis bietet also muss man
ganz klar sagen was was die Technik
angeht was die Reichweite angeht was die
Lage Infrastruktur angeht das war ja
auch ein Punkt warum ja muss ich Tesla
eben getraut hat ins Risiko zu gehen und
zu sagen wir machen den Gesamtpaket wir
haben eine Ladeinfrastruktur die
funktioniert und sie funktioniert eben
auch und deshalb ja ist das Gesamtpaket
plus Lieferzeiten ein Tesla konnte man
immer innerhalb von paar Wochen zwei
drei Monaten bekommen das war aber den
deutschen Autobauern ein Problem und
eben weil wir VW schon angesprochen
haben die ersten Elektroautos von VW
waren jetzt halt auch ja technisch nicht
gerade oder auch so Innenraum mäßig
nicht gerade auf der auf der Höhe der
Zeit und sie hat mir auch
Softwareprobleme und alles also es war
einfach tesla hat diese er hat diese
Vakuum genutzt und ist auch dann jetzt
immer noch weil sie jetzt gerade auch
wieder Preise senken muss man ja auch
sagen sie haben halt die Kapazitäten die
Marge dass sie auch mal Preise senken
können ist das für viele Menschen halt
einfach immer noch so dass das beste
Komplettpaket nicht für alle aber für
viele und jetzt kommen auch noch die
billigen Chinesen also zunehmend
kleinere erschwingliche Modelle vom
chinesischen Markt
wie gut sind diese Autos made in China
es gab jetzt eine größere Untersuchung
des Spiegels jetzt gerade an diesem
Wochenende die sich acht Autos mal
angeschaut haben wobei man auch sagen
muss das Wort preiswert würde ich da
auch nicht bei jedem dieser Modelle
verwenden da gibt es Modelle die auch
zwischen 30.000 40.000 teilweise sogar
noch drüber liegen teilweise auch die
Situation das fand ich ganz kurios ich
fasse sie mehr welche Anbieter es war wo
man das Auto kaufen kann die Batterie
aber extra kaufen muss und dann auch
zwischen zwei Batterie Qualitäten dann
auch noch sich entscheiden muss wo in
vierstelliger Betrag dann liegt also ähm
aber auch mit Reichweiten die durchaus
überhaupt der 400 km zumindestens in
diesen Fahrtest Zyklen liegen auf der
Straße mag das dann immer noch anders
aussehen was natürlich interessant ist
ist der Punkt Software und meiner
Ansicht nach liegt dort halt auch ein
bisschen der Knackpunkt wir haben jetzt
viele über die Technik geredet die in
dem Auto verbaut ist und von A nach B zu
kommen also das heißt um sie auf der
Straße zu bewegen um es aufzuladen das
was aber der chinesische Markt zeigt ist
das auch Entertainment navigation
Immunsysteme die Kommunikation des Autos
mit dem Telefon was ist was zumindest
für den chinesischen Markt sehr wichtig
ist wo deutsche Autobauer darin liegt
die Chance auch lernen können über diese
Bedürfnisse aber letztendlich halt auch
lernen müssen um sich darauf
einzustellen und ich glaube gerade für
Volkswagen wird das noch ein harter
Prozess mit der Software Sparte die halt
auch nicht so ganz reibungslos läuft
also ich glaube dieses wegkommen von das
Auto ist ein Hardware Produkt mit einem
wundervoll mechanisch völlig
ausgereiftem Verbrennungsmotor der sich
gut anfühlt und toll fährt diese Zeiten
sind irgendwie vorbei es sind jetzt
irgendwie andere Spielfelder und da muss
diese Aufholjagd bei den deutschen
Herstellern nachdem was ich bislang so
gesehen habe
dringend noch stattfinden und
offensichtliche sind die Chinesen in den
Entwicklungszyklen da auch schneller das
dauert in Deutschland dann doch durchaus
noch zu lange bis man dort neue
Ergebnisse auch hat Frau Elvers sind die
Deutschen da schon auf der Höhe der Zeit
also dieses Smartphone auf Rädern dass
hier manchmal so spöttisch über den
Tesla gesagt wird ist es das was auch
die deutschen Autobauer schon im Blick
haben ja im Blick haben sie das
natürlich aber sie haben erhebliche
Probleme das zeigt ja der die Baustelle
kariert bei VW also gibt es erhebliche
Probleme da wird jetzt gerade wieder
versucht das nach vorne zu bringen aber
das zeichnet sich eben noch nicht ab
dass das ja so schnell passieren wird
und Tesla ist ja auch deshalb so
erfolgreich weil es eigentlich ein
Softair Konzern ist ja der Autobauer
schafft es da ein ein ja ein Gesamtpaket
zu bieten was ja Fahrvergnügen bietet
oder was vernetzt ist und ähm ja dann
eben die Ansprüche an einen ja modernes
E-Auto dann auch erfüllt und genauso die
Chinesen die natürlich auch sehr viel
schneller unterwegs sind in der
Entwicklung von Lindner hat gerade schon
angesprochen also Volkswagen braucht bis
ein neues Produkt auf dem Markt ist vier
Jahre die Chinesen nur zwei das ist
natürlich in diesen schnellen
Innovationszyklen in denen wir uns heute
befinden dann schon problematisch wenn
man da noch aufholen will was muss
passieren wie kommt das wieso sind die
deutschen Autobauer also so langsam so
so mühsam nur anpassungsfähig an den
Zeitgeist
ich weiß noch gar nicht ob das der
Zeitgeist ist und wir reden auf die
ganze Zeit über Volkswagen es gibt ich
wenn man schon mal eine Marke nennen
will dann empfehle ich doch mal jedem
BMW E7 zu fahren das Elektroauto von BMW
da merkt man nämlich den Unterschied
zwischen einem mittelmäßigen Auto und
einem sehr guten Auto und das ist
vielleicht für manches ist irgendwie
egal geworden und dann geht's nur noch
um den Bildschirm und ich halte das für
eine Normalität dass diese Bildschirme
gut funktionieren müssen dass die
Handynutzung gut oder die Verbindung gut
funktionieren muss aber ein Auto besteht
jedenfalls nach meiner Vorstellung schon
auch noch aus Fahrwerk Lenkung Bremse
und da macht uns bis jetzt keiner was
vor ich kenne viele chinesische Autos
wir sind sie eigentlich alle Gefahren in
unserer Redaktion ist ja auch unsere
Aufgabe es gibt ein zwei die fahren
wirklich beeindruckend gut und da hätte
ich auch große Sorgen davor wenn die
hier noch mehr stärker auf den Markt
kommen
aber die allermeisten das sind wir schon
noch wesentlich besser und da wäre ich
jetzt mal nicht so pessimistisch wir
werden zur IAA von BMW und von Mercedes
2 Autos sehen die wirklich weit in die
Zukunft reichen und auch im elektrischen
Antrieb Maßstäbe setzen werden ich habe
sie beide schon gesehen darf es aber
leider nicht erzählen jetzt hier
genaueres aber das hat mich schon
beeindruckt und deswegen bin ich da auch
nicht so pessimistisch in Deutschland
geht ja tatsächlich immer noch stark um
den Preis wir haben schon drüber
gesprochen im Moment sind viele
Elektroauto Elektroautos einfach
unerschwinglich für viele Menschen
gebrauchte gibt es noch so gut wie gar
keine das kommen noch dazu wann wird es
günstige deutsche Einstiegsmodelle geben
ja gut VW kündigt ja an dass sie in zwei
Jahren glaube ich ist jetzt da stand den
idy 2 bringen der dann irgendwie so um
die 25000 € kosten soll und ja also das
ist jetzt so der der Horizont aber viele
verabschieden sich ja auch schon von
diesen kleinen Wagen also das sagen wir
es lohnt sich gar nicht mehr das
Mobilität bezahlbar halten das ist die
große Frage die ist nämlich nicht
sichtbar im Moment also es wird
natürlich mit sie geben und der
Gebrauchtwagenmarkt wird natürlich auch
größer werden die Autos die jetzt eben
gekauft werden die werden natürlich dann
in zwei drei Jahren auch zu günstigeren
Preisen kommen aber ich sehe das total
dass man ja einen kleinen Wagen eben ich
sehe es immer bei mir wenn ich bei
meinem Auto was vorbei laufe da stehen
dann die Fiat 500 Elektro für 38000 €,
wo ich mir sage klar es ist ein cooles
Auto habe oder ich kann das
unterschreiben ich fahre einen aber ich
sehe natürlich dass das für Menschen
unerschwinglich ist vor allem halt
gerade Kleinwagen kaufen ja eben viele
Menschen nicht neu sondern dann guck mal
noch mehr auf den Preis und sagt ich
kaufe auch jetzt neu kein Kleinwagen für
20.000 € und dass man da ein Problem hat
ist logisch aber andererseits es werden
jedes Jahr sehr viele Autos neu
zugelassen der
durchschnittsneuerwagenpreis liegt weit
über 40.000
von daher kann man ja schon sagen wenn
wir aber wenn diese Autos jetzt
zugelassen werden warum müssen dann noch
so viele davon Verbrenner oder
Plug-in-Hybride sein da kann man sich
nicht geben warum die Auftragseingänge
im Moment so schwach sind und weil der
Dachstuhl brennt bei VW der brennt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur dort warum die
Leute nicht zugreifen und ich habe mir
die Mühe gemacht hier im Vorfeld mal
zwei drei Händler anzurufen und zu
fragen die sagen die private Nachfrage
tendiert gegen Null nach neuen
Elektroautos und der Zweitmarkt ist ein
riesen Problem denn früher ist es immer
so gewesen es ist mit dem Benzinern so
dass die Autos nach irgendeiner Zeit
Richtung aus Europa abwandern in
Osteuropa interessiert sich aber keinen
Hund für die Elektroautos das heißt die
bleiben hier und verstopfen den Markt
wir werden auf auf diesem Bereich ein
heule und Zähne klappern erleben
innerhalb der nächsten 6 oder 12 Monate
und mit momentan wird das alles
überdeckt durch die tollen
Zulassungszahlen die aber aus dem
letzten Jahr her rühren wo die Leute in
Deutschland typisch es gibt eine
Subvention oder eine Steuererleichterung
dann springe ich drauf und macht noch
mit jetzt ist das weg von mir aus könnte
sie ganz weg dann würde man den
richtigen Preis sehen und dann wird es
ganz ganz schwer hier in dem Markt
wie der sich dann aufteilt beschreiben
sie mal das Heulen und Seele klappern
dass sie da prognostizieren naja wir
werden mit denen die werden die Preise
werden sich nicht halten lassen und die
Absatzzahlen werden werden nicht
funktionieren wir werden die 10 oder 15
Millionen nicht erreichen nach heutigem
Stand und ich weiß im Moment nicht ganz
genau wie wir das auflösen wollen beim
verbrennerverbot in der EU das ja 2035
in Kraft treten soll hat Deutschland ja
Ausnahmen für Autos durchgesetzt die nur
mit ifuels fahren ist das ein
Hoffnungsschimmer für die Branche oder
eigentlich verhängnisvoll bei der
weiteren Entwicklung also das ist so ein
so ein Feigenblatt dass nichts von der
Realität zu tun hat also kein deutscher
Autohersteller hat irgendwie eine
Aussage getätigt dass sie zwar nach 20
35 noch Neuwagen als Verbrenner zulassen
wollen von daher ist es so ein bisschen
ich bin überhaupt nicht gegen dieses ich
finde es wichtig dass man die wenn man
die fördert dass dort dass sie
produziert werden ich sehe auch dieses
Thema bestandsflotte alles gut aber
diese Frage ob man nach 2035 also dass
man als
Autofahrer sagt ich warte jetzt so lange
und ich kaufe mir kein Elektroauto weil
ich setze darauf dass ja nach 2035 ich
dann meinen tollen Verbrenner habe und
e-fuels habe die in der Menge verfügbar
sind die im Preis okay sind das ist für
mich einfach Quatsch und das wird auch
nicht passieren das ist so ein bisschen
dieses psychologische naja man hält
irgendwie dem Hund so wie die Wurst noch
wo die Nase was da irgendwann kommt aber
es wird einfach realistisch nicht
passieren
die Schwierigkeit die ich im Moment sehe
ist dass man ja noch nicht dass es
bislang nur eine politische Einigung ist
dass man halt wirklich noch überhaupt
nicht weiß wie soll denn dieser Typ Auto
eigentlich aussehen also es gab jetzt
eine weitere nickeligkeit einer weiteren
ich würde mal sagen Streit auch zwischen
Herrn Zimmermanns der eigentlich
erinnert an das was man davor gesehen
hat es gab einen Brandbrief aus dem
Verkehrsministerium jetzt im Juni kam
wurde der öffentlich gerichtet an Herrn
Timmermanns stellt vertretender
Kommissionspräsident der Europäischen
Kommission wo er bisschen gesagt hat wir
haben uns doch im Laufe dieses Jahres
darauf verständigt dass es diesen neuen
Typ geben soll nämlich e-fields only
Verbrenner ab 2035 wir warten jetzt
darauf dass man technisch ausformuliert
wird wie dieses Auto denn eigentlich
gestaltet werden soll und wie zum
Beispiel halt auch sichergestellt werden
soll und das ist ein Punkt auf den ich
wirklich gespannt bin dass dieses Auto
dann nur mit efuels fährt es wurden zwei
Varianten diskutiert aber die gibt es
bislang halt auch noch nicht auf dem
Markt über einen Sensor im Tank bzw im
Motor oder über anders gestaltete
Einfüllstutzen und ich habe mir damals
diesen dieselskandal seit 2015 in voller
Schönheit inklusive
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
angeschaut und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen mein Vertrauen in das was Sensorik
oder einzelstutzen oder irgendeine
andere Art von Messtechnik heißt
ich da wirklich also von begrenzter von
begrenztem Umfang ich kann ja nur
zustimmen ich hatte ja schon anfangs
gesagt die e-fuels sind nicht der
Zaubertrank der uns in die Zukunft
retten wird also wir brauchen ihn fuels
aber die brauchen wir eben für Schiffe
die brauchen wir für Flugzeuge das
gleiche gilt auch für Wasserstoff den
brauchen wir eben um die
energieintensive Industrie Klima neutral
zu bekommen ja aber wenn wir uns jetzt
auf diesen nehmen Schauplatz
konzentrieren anstatt mit aller
Innovationskraft eben auf den auf die
Zukunft auf die Immobilität zu gehen ja
dann freut sich die Konkurrenz und wir
haben das Nachsehen lassen Sie uns jetzt
vielleicht im
verbleibenden letzten Drittel der
Sendung noch auf die Dinge gucken die
jetzt zu tun sind also was kann auch die
Politik Unternehmen wie ist es mit Blick
auf Subventionen auf Schutzprogramme wie
kann die Politik unterstützen und die
Autobauer in Deutschland stärken also um
die eigene Industrie stark zu machen
subventiert so pensioniert ja zum
Beispiel die chinesische Regierung mit
Milliarden
war China vor der Pandemie nur der sechs
größte automobil-exporteur der Welt so
liegt es heute ganz weit vorne muss die
Bundesregierung im Gegenzug ebenso stark
subventionieren
ich bin ja grundsätzlich gegen die
Subventionen sowieso ich würde an der
Stelle Herrn Tavares vielleicht mal
zitieren dürfen das ist der Chef von
stellantis das kennt man sie nicht so
aber das ist Opel und Fiat und Peugeot
und die großen mal zu nennen und der
sagt es gibt kein level playing field ja
die Chinesen dürfen nach Europa rein
ohne irgendwelche Hürden und wir haben
dort große Schwierigkeiten in den Markt
rein zu kommen weil man eben einen Joint
Venture Partner immer braucht oder sonst
noch nicht Tarife Hemmnisse gibt und
wenn wir nicht rechtzeitig Aufwachen
dann werden wir ein böses Erwachen
erleben
er macht das mit sehr markigen Worten
und daher das Unternehmen mit relativ
großen Erfolg führt würde ich sagen er
ist einigermaßen ernst zu nehmen
wir Unterstützung durch die Stadt
Subventionen sind aber keine Antwort
okay ja es ist ja so dass nicht nur in
Deutschland die Automobilindustrie
nervös ist sondern beispielsweise auch
in Frankreich und da gab es jetzt ein
bemerkenswerten Vorstoß von dem
Präsidenten Emmanuel macron der im
früher vorgeschlagen hat oder Erwägung
gezogen hat dass man dort die
e-autoförderung so anpassen könnte dass
eben bestimmte Kriterien eingefügt
werden womit die Chinesen dann quasi
draußen werden also ein Versuch sie
auszubremsen muss man dazu sagen dass
natürlich die Franzosen längst nicht so
exponiert sind im chinesischen Markt die
deutschen deswegen kann man sich
womöglich solche Überlegungen auch
leisten aber
das ist natürlich keine Strategie und da
sind auch die deutschen Autobauer
dagegen also wir werden nicht
wettbewerbsfähig indem wir die ja die
Konkurrenz ausbremsen sondern wir müssen
sie ja eigentlich überholen und da ist
es dann natürlich Aufgabe der Politik
auch jetzt nicht mit weiteren
weiteren gießkannten Subventionen zu
verstreuen sondern den Standort
insgesamt zu verbessern ja ich bleibe
noch mal da wie wäre es denn z.B damit
die Kaufprämie wieder hochzusetzen oder
die Strompreise für E-Autos zu senken
eine gute Idee
gerade Thema Strompreise habe ich mich
immer gefragt warum gilt die
strompreisbremse nicht für Ladestrom
wäre auch wenn wir sagen damals wir
haben den Tankrabatt gemacht um den ja
um Benzin Diesel günstiger zu halten
haben wir es aber bei den Strompreisen
nicht geschafft dass man eben sagt ich
zahl auch nur an der öffentlichen
Ladesäule eben 40 Cent wäre auch eine
Maßnahme gewesen natürlich wenn ich zu
Hause laden kann und meine Solaranlage
habe ist das alles kein Thema wenn ich
aber öffentlich laden muss komme ich
zumindest was die reinen Energiekosten
angeht teilweise also genauso teuer oder
sogar ein bisschen teurer als mit meinem
Verbrenner von daher ist das sind das
natürlich Fragen genau wie denn äh die
die Infrastruktur eben überhaupt
auszubauen die sozusagen ich jeder
Arbeitgeber ist verpflichtet den
Menschen anzubieten dass sie ihr Auto
laden können öffentliche Einrichtungen
brauchen dass jeder jedes Parkhaus und
das sind einfach Punkte wo man dran muss
aber das ist meiner Meinung nach besser
als jetzt den Auto Modell an die
Subventionen direkt zu geben und zu
sagen hier kriegt ihr noch mehr Geld
weil am Ende muss man ja auch sagen
müssen sie es halt auch ein bisschen mal
selber lösen und ja gucken dass die da
rauskommen so würde ich auch sehen also
ich habe so das Gefühl dass das was
Volker Wissing in punkto ladeausbau der
Lade Infrastruktur betreibt ich finde es
ist so ein bisschen
unmotiviert und uninspiriert also es gab
zwar im vergangenen Herbst den
Masterplan da der Infrastruktur Nummer
zwei mit 68 Maßnahmen die auch alle
irgendwie jetzt nicht schlecht sind aber
die meiner Ansicht nach nicht den
Durchbruch bringen und die auch den
Punkt finde ich der Digitalisierung dort
noch zu schwach adressieren was ich
eigentlich schade finde weil hier
deswegen ist ja nicht nur
Verkehrsminister ist ja auch digital
Minister plus die FDP hat sich die
Digitalisierung der Wirtschaft und auch
irgendwie das gesellschaftlichen Lebens
wie keine andere Partei auf die Farben
geschrieben ist dafür auch gewählt
worden und da könnte man z.B was das
Thema Apps angeht Verfügbarkeit in
diesem Masterplan wird auch über
reservierbark Welt von Ladesäulen unter
anderem gesprochen was alles schön ist
es soll jetzt zum Spätsommer wenigstens
ein neues ausschreibungsprogramm geben
wo man der Industrie die man schon auch
als primären Verantwortlichen für den
Ausbau der Infrastruktur sieht nochmal
unter die Arme greift vor allem für
Standorte in deutschen Regionen die
jetzt nicht so wirklich auf den
allerersten Blick dann
wirtschaftlich betrieben werden können
aber mein Eindruck ist auch von der
Förderpolitik dass das im Moment total
durcheinander also dass das ein
Zickzackkurs ist der total durcheinander
geht man hat die Kaufprämie die jetzt
gesenkt wurde die auch im kommenden Jahr
noch mal abgesenkt wird die auch und ich
glaube das wird noch mal ein Einschnitt
sein zum ersten September nur noch für
Privatleute gilt das heißt nicht mehr
z.B für Freiberufler nicht mehr für
Firmen das heißt auch dieser ganze Punkt
das ist ja vor allem Firmen sind
70% der 19 der neuzulassen denn neu
zugelassenen Wagen waren durch Firmen
zugelassen das zeigt die
Halbjahresbilanz
ist also da schneidet man sich ab ich
halte es im Kern auch für richtig an
diese Subventionen ranzugehen auf der
anderen Seite gibt es jetzt den nächsten
Fördertopf von Wissing 500 Millionen
Euro für wallboxen und auch Speicher die
man sich zu Hause dann einbauen kann
allerdings nur wenn man nachweisen kann
dass man schon E-Auto hat also hier habe
ich das Gefühl da ist man irgendwie so
ein bisschen
breitspurig unterwegs und in den
richtigen Schwung und auch
eine Adressierung dessen das ist
durchaus auch für den für den Alltag der
Menschen wenn sie zum Beispiel über ein
Eigenheim verfügen auch durchaus
Vorteile haben kann mit der
eigenstromproduktion auf dem
Eigenverbrauch da finde ich das alles
noch ein bisschen zaghaft man sieht es
auch irgendwie es gibt neue
steuerregulierung jetzt für den
Eigenverbrauch aber ich habe das Gefühl
so richtig aus einem Guss ist es nicht
und es wird auch nicht aus einem Guss
kommuniziert und das halte ich sehr sehr
schade übrigens wieder bei den
Einfamilienhäusern ne also das
innenstadtproblem Laden ist immer noch
nicht gelöst und ich wüsste jetzt auch
nicht ganz genau warum eigentlich das
eine staatliche Aufgabe sein soll eine
Lade Infrastruktur aufzubauen es haben
sie über den Tankstellen meines Wissens
auch nicht gemacht wenn das sie hatten
es angeschnitten wenn das ein
Geschäftsmodell wäre der die Ladestation
unterwegs sein würde ist schon private
Initiative geben wir haben das
ionity-netzwerk das macht das viele
andere kommen nicht weil es sich nicht
lohnt und trotzdem kostet eine
Kilowattstunde Strom unterwegs an der
Autobahn mindestens 75 Zentrum zum Teil
1 € mindestens 75 Cent das stimmt nicht
das stimmt ja ich hab's ich habe es
heute morgen bei meinem Anbieter
nachgeguckt sie kostet 75 Cent bei
ionity an der Stelle es gibt ganz viele
andere Anbieter gibt
der größte Anbieter
okay und zum Teil wenn sie spontan Laden
einen Euro da kommen sie mit dem
Elektroauto teurer als mit jedem Diesel
auf der Fernstrecke das kann doch die
Leute nicht überzeugen ja die können
rechnen die wissen sie müssen öfter
laden dann wird es auch noch teuer
unterwegs das kann nicht funktionieren
also Strompreis muss runter und für die
Industrie würde ich sagen wir brauchen
dringenden Bürokratieabbau und wieder
mehr Vertrauen in die Unternehmer das
wäre für die wirklich hilfreich wir sind
schon dabei den Blick in die Zukunft zu
werfen dass wir die wichtig am Ende
dieser Runde und dieser Sendung zur
E-Mobilität machen wir das mal wie wird
sich der Automobilmarkt in den nächsten
Jahren entwickeln wie wird sich zum
Beispiel die Modellpalette verändern sie
wird sich hoffentlich ausweiten also
auch trotz aller Hemmnisse auch für den
sozusagen moderat bezahlbaren Markt
Ausbau des gebrauchtwagenmarktes da
hoffe ich sehr darauf und es gibt noch
einen Punkt ich wollte ihnen eben gerade
widersprechen aber dann mache ich es
halt einfach jetzt in der Schlussrunde
man geht immer man hat ja auch keinen
statisches Umfeld sie haben CO2-Preis
der auch für Kraftstoffe im Verkehr gilt
wo jetzt der nächste Stufe zum
Jahreswechsel wieder kommt das werden in
etwa vier bis fünf Cent sowohl für
Benzin als auch diese sein und das ist
ein Vater nach oben geht also das heißt
jedes Jahr wieder wird diese
Entscheidung neu getroffen werden und
sie wird unter anderem Umständen
getroffen werden und mit dem Strompreis
und das ist natürlich was das
Unterschreiben Ihnen die
energieintensiven Unternehmen das
unterschreibt ihn quasi die gesamte
deutsche Industrie das ist ja jetzt
nicht nur ein verbraucherthema wo es
eine Baustelle gibt das ist was wo ich
denke was standortpolitisch extrem
wichtig ist was auch erkannt wurde aber
ich habe das Gefühl auch durch habe ich
noch nicht ausreichend mit Lösungen
hinterlegt Frau Alvares was kommt auf
die deutsche Automobilindustrie zu und
wofür muss sie sich jetzt mal dringend
wappnen naja sie muss sich dringend
natürlich weiter für die Konkurrenz und
die chinesischen Hersteller haben hier
tatsächlich bisher eher ein geringen
Marktanteil also die Zeit die der
Automobilindustrie noch bleibt die
sollte sie jetzt tatsächlich nutzen und
ihre volle Innovationskraft die ich auch
zutraue auf die Straße bringen im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes aber klar ist
auch dass sie da jetzt nicht auf weitere
Milliardensubventionen hoffen sollte
denn der Staat kann ja nicht die
Vollkaskoversicherung für die
Versäumnisse der Industrie sein
wir entscheiden sind die nächsten Jahre
und die Entwicklungsschritte die
Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit der
deutschen Autoindustrie für unseren
Wohlstand und für den
Wirtschaftsstandort ja erheblich wir
haben eben nicht nur aufs Klima zu
achten sondern auch auf den
wirtschaftlichen Standort ich hoffe wir
sind uns alle einig dass wir doch ein
Industriestandort bleiben wollen und
insofern wäre ich froh wenn die
Industrie stark ist und wenn Sie
innovativ ist vielleicht mal ein
Beispiel wir haben ja auch als wir der
Meinung waren die Glühbirne Verbrauch zu
viel Strom nicht das Licht verboten
sondern die LED erfunden und in dem
Sinne wäre es mir sehr recht wenn wir
die Industrie auch motivieren können
vielen Dank das war unsere
Runde Autos verliert die deutsche
Autoindustrie den Anschluss danke an
meine Gäste danke für die spannende
Runde danke für äh zuschauen und ihr
Interesse hier geht's jetzt weiter mit
dem europamagazin eines der Themen ist
Spanien von den Wahlen die Angst vor dem
Rechtsruck und den Presseclub
nachgefragt den können Sie jetzt gleich
wie immer auf Phoenix und dem Radio auf
WDR 5 verfolgen ich danke Ihnen für
Interesse und wir alle hier wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen
Sonntagnachmittag danke
[Musik]
so und da sind wir direkt wieder
willkommen zum Presseclub nachgefragt
jetzt ist Zeit für ihre Meinung Ihre
Fragen zu unserem Thema und wir beginnen
direkt mit Tanja Krause aus Hanau hallo
Frau Krause Ihre Frage ihre Position
bitte ja hallo schönen guten Tag und
zwar möchte ich meine apfelrecht geben
es ist ja für Leute die in der
Innenstadt wohnen absolut unmöglich eine
Ladestation zu finden und damit schließt
man Millionen von Menschen vom Markt aus
die werden sich niemals in ihr Auto
kaufen was überhaupt keine Möglichkeit
haben dass sie ihr Auto laden zu können
auch wenn man das Geld dafür hätte
also wie stellt man sich das vor dass
jeder E-Autos fährt oder haben die Leute
dann schlichten einfach Pech gehabt und
dann gibt es halt keine Autos mehr
möchten Sie möchten Sie noch eine Frage
dazu formulieren
ja also ist es dann nicht möglich
weiterhin mit efuel zu fahren zumal das
ja auch mit Bioenergie oder so weiter
auch umweltverträglich zu machen ist und
CO2 neutral hergestellt werden kann
danke Frau Krause für Ihre Frage wir
haben die schon auf den Apple bezogen
aber Frau Kunkel bringt sehr ähnliche
Antwort ich sag's auch gerne aus
persönlich Erfahrung ich wohne in der
Innenstadt von München ich habe ein
E-Auto und ich sehe genau dieses Problem
also ich sehe zunehmend das ist
schwieriger wird dort eine freie
Ladesäule zu finden weil dort eben im
Moment kein Ausbau stattfindet die
andere Frage ist steht mein Auto in der
Innenstadt den ganzen Tag wäre es dann
nicht so wenn ich sage ich fahre zu
meinem Arbeitgeber und ich könnte bei
meinem Arbeitgeber laden oder ich kann
laden wenn ich einkaufen fahre also mein
Auto steht ja nicht immer in Innenstadt
also man muss ja sich überlegen wo steht
es denn rum gibt es ja eine Möglichkeit
zu sagen ich lade dort plus dann sind
wir wieder bei der Frage wie viel Autos
brauche ich überhaupt in der Innenstadt
also ist es nicht in der Zukunft eher
vielleicht auch eine Idee zu sagen wir
machen den den öffentlichen Nahverkehr
so dass man wenn möglich gar kein Auto
mehr in der Innenstadt braucht aber dass
das schwieriger ist mit einem E-Auto
ohne eigene Lademöglichkeit in der Stadt
bin ich total dabei als wenn ich jetzt
eben auf der auf dem Land wohne und zum
leer zum Thema e-fuels habe es ja vorhin
schon mal angeschnitten dass diese
Technik grundsätzlich funktioniert das
ist diese ifuls geben wird und geben
kann bin ich total dabei aber die Frage
ist halt eben sind sie wann sind Sie
verfügbar in der Menge dass sie auch für
die ja Autoindustrie oder für Autos da
sind plus was ist der Preis dafür also
es kann ja auch nicht das Ziel sein dass
man dann ja sozusagen
gibt es von den Stromkonzern jedenfalls
Ideen dass man vielleicht lade Inseln
baut irgendwo um eine Verkehrsinsel
drumherum oder sowas mit vier fünf
lade andockt Möglichkeiten und dann
müssen sie dann aber natürlich nach drei
Stunden irgendwann wieder wegfahren auch
im Zweifel mitten in der Nacht sonst
werden sie mit standortzuschlägen belegt
denn es sollen ja möglichst viele diese
Möglichkeit haben da müsste man in den
Städten eben noch eine entsprechende
Infrastruktur schaffen die es bis jetzt
nicht zu sehen okay vielen dank danke
Frau Krause für Ihre Frage und hier
kommt schon die nächste Frage von Jürgen
Bongard aus Köln hallo Herr Baumgart
guten Tag in die Runde meine vorhörerin
hat das Thema was ich mir am Herzen
liegt eigentlich schon angesprochen ich
möchte es präzisieren
die Frage die Runde nicht wie kommt wo
kommt der Strom her sondern die Frage
die Runde wie kommt der Strom vor Ort
und diese Frage ist von den
Befürwortern der Mobilität bisher völlig
ausgeklammert worden hat die überhaupt
nicht interessiert dabei ist dass die
eigentliche Frage wir sind ein Volk von
laternenparkern
so jeder der auf der Straße parken hat
nach meinem Vorstellungen das Recht auch
versorgt zu werden mit Strom aber wie
soll das geschehen es reicht nicht aus
indem man einfach Ladestationen
aufstellt das ist einfach aber die
müssen noch versorgt werden ich will ein
Beispiel nennen eigentlich
ist es wir sollen ja auch LKWs
umgerüstet werden auf
Stromer als als Stromer ein LKW normaler
S40 Tonner LKW nehmen wir mal zehn Stück
die brauchen zu die brauchen für einen
Strom etwa 50 50 Megabyte
wenn Sie wenn die versorgt werden wollen
so
wo sollen die 50 Megabyte herkommen ich
glaube wir sind uns einig dass die
Lastwagen nicht werden Lastwagen bis auf
Weiteres mit Wasserstoff fahren werden
wenn sie denn was anderes machen werden
mit Strom werden sie das auf dem
Fernverkehr nicht hinkriegen bis auf
weiteres ich glaube das ist aber auch
einigermaßen unstrittig jetzt erstmal
ähm
gesehen die Lkw-Bauer offensichtlich
anders also die es gibt ein zwei Modelle
denn von von von Mercedes aber diese
Frage wie kommt der Strom an die Stelle
wo er gebraucht wird nämlich wirklich an
die Laterne Frau Alvares haben sie eine
Antwort
ja
ich er kommt natürlich hoffentlich an
die Laterne in dem das Ladenetz einfach
schnell weiter ausgebaut wird ja wir
müssen eigentlich täglich jetzt 365
Ladesäulen aufstellen um diese
lade-infrastruktur tatsächlich auch in
die Breite zu bringen nicht nur in den
Städten sondern natürlich auch im Land
und das sehe ich bisher noch nicht ich
kann mich dann nur mal kurz wiederholen
also ich hoffe ja das Auto steht nicht
24 Stunden am Tag an der Laterne sondern
man hat ja ein Auto um sich irgendwo
hinzubewegen und wenn dort wo ich mich
hinbewege und dann eben bin meistens ja
auch für ein paar Stunden oder mal eine
halbe oder eine Stunde dass ich dann da
mein Auto laden kann das muss ja das
Ziel sein wir nehmen die nächste
ZuschauerInnen mit in die Diskussionen
denn dafür ist diese Sendung ja da der
nachgefragt Renate Luther aus Oberursel
ist am Apparat hallo Frau Luther Ihre
Frage bitte hallo in die Runde ich finde
ein E-Auto ist auch nicht
umweltfreundlicher als ein Benziner das
Klima wird immer vorgeschoben ich frage
mich die Lebensdauer des der Batterie
ist sehr gering was wird mit den
Batterien gemacht wenn die nicht wenn
die ihren Geist aufgegeben haben wo
kommt die hin wer entsorgt die das ist
gar nicht so einfach schicken wir die
einfach in die armen Länder wo man auch
das Kobold und Silizium herkriegen auf
Kosten dieser Menschen wollen wir eh
Auto fahren ja wir wollen gute Luft
haben und die Menschen dort den wird das
Grundwasser entzogen ich weiß nicht ob
sie schon mal so in in in diesen Ländern
waren und haben sich sowas mal angeguckt
eigentlich finde ich
ist ein E-Auto auch nur für reiche Leute
ich zum Beispiel könnte mir so ein Auto
gar nicht kaufen
obwohl ich 49 Jahre gearbeitet habe das
ist vielleicht bei dir Herrschaften die
bei ihnen sitzen die können sich sowas
leisten ich nicht so vielen Dank und
viele andere auch nicht und mit diesem
Batterien da werden wir ein ganz großes
Problem kriegen
nicht mehr in Ordnung sind wo kommen die
hin das würde mich jetzt mal wer
entsorgt die ja das würde mich jetzt mal
interessieren vielen Dank für diese
Frage Frau Luther ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtige Frage und eine Sorge die ganz
viele Menschen umtreibt Frau Lindner
schreibt mit sie hat eine Antwort ich
kann ihn jetzt nicht sagen wo Sie ganz
konkret die Batterie hinbringen ich kann
Ihnen sagen dass die Idee die dahinter
steht dieses Problem erkannt hat und
adressiert nämlich dass man stärker auf
Kreislaufwirtschaft und Recycling setzt
weil man eben genau um die Knappheit der
Rohstoffe weiß
wir haben über China gesprochen china
ist ein wichtiger Produzent von Seltenen
Erden fährt aber auch
dann hat die Entscheidung zu Gallium
exportverbote jetzt gesehen auch eine
aggressive Rohstoffpolitik also das
heißt wenn man sich die Eckpunkte zur
Rohstoffstrategie der Bundesregierung
anschaut steht da ganz oben drauf wie es
Kreislaufwirtschaft also das heißt man
hat ein Produkt man verwendet man
zerlegt es in die Bestandteile verwendet
es wieder Recycling und dann halt aber
auch effizienter Ressourceneinsatz das
ist ein Punkt der da kommt man meiner
Ansicht nach nicht drumherum Update zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt schon dort ist wo er
eigentlich hin soll das bezweifle ich
aber ich glaube dieser Fokus ist klar
und zur Umweltbilanz würde ich ihn ein
bisschen widersprechen wollen dass sie
so schlecht nicht ist wenn man die
gesamten Lebenszyklus betrachtet man hat
jetzt die Zahlen für Mai sagen für
Deutschland dass man 60% Ökostrom sauber
grün produzierten Strom im Stromnetz hat
mit dem ist man schon unterwegs das geht
über den Winter dann ein bisschen runter
aber da kommt man nicht drum rum und sie
haben natürlich auch in einem regulären
Auto eine Batterie man hat doch in einem
regulären Auto Halbleiter das heißt man
verbraucht dort auch Ressourcen Stahl
etc pp also das heißt diese
diese
Produktionskosten die anfallen auch CO2
technisch umwelttechnisch anfallen die
hat man ja bei beiden Produkten okay
vielen dank ähm gleich der nächste Anruf
war Oliver harbusch aus Kassel Grüße
nach Kassel und ihre Frage
ich habe eine Frage
und zwar vielleicht gleich drei Fragen
mit der Bitte um eine kurze Antwort also
das eine ist
ich verstehe die Diskussion nicht so
ganz mit dem entweder oder also entweder
Verbrenner oder oder
Elektroauto weil es hat ja auch beides
irgendwie so ein Stück weit auch eine
Berechtigung je nachdem wo es angewendet
wird ich sag mal so der Verbrenner kann
ja beispielsweise halt auch wesentlich
effektiver ähm
laufend also es gibt beispielsweise das
letzte Frage an den Apple wissen Sie
eigentlich dass er seit 20 Jahren in 1
Liter Auto gibt von VW
lass mal den Apfel direkt drauf
antworten
ich habe da sogar drin gesessen das kann
ich Ihnen sagen ja das war das weiß ich
die Sache ist ja ganz einfach die Autos
müssen ins Leben passen und das ist
genau die Entscheidung die jeder für
sich persönlich treffen muss deswegen
ich werde dir oft gefragt was soll ich
mir als nächstes kaufen dann frage ich
erstmal ab wie fährst du damit wie
nutzte ist und die Kollegin hat gesagt
sie fährt das Elektroauto weil sie eben
viel auch in dem städtischen Bereich
unterwegs ist ich finde da passt es
jetzt schon ganz gut hin wenn man den
Anschaffungspreis eben irgendwie sich
leisten kann oder leisten möchte man
will ja vielleicht auch ein Statement
damit setzen finde ich gut und für
andere passt es nicht weil ja oft das
Auto ein erstes Auto ist in einer
Familie und ähm nicht jeder sich ein
Zweitauto für 40 50.000 € leisten kann
oder möchte insofern ja natürlich ist es
nicht entweder oder sondern sowohl als
auch deswegen sage ich auch ich hätte
gern die technologieoffenheit okay ja
aber vielen Dank für Ihren Anruf vielen
Dank für Ihre Frage und der nächste
Anrufer ist Wolfgang Schuld aus München
Herr Schuld Ihre Frage ihre Position zu
unserem Thema bitte
ja
München
ich versuche es mal kurz einzuführen
mich ärgert ist ein bisschen dass das
E-Auto immer mit dem Verbrenner
verglichen wird meine Einschätzung nach
ist es eigentlich etwas völlig anderes
und auch als das Auto auf dem Markt
gekommen ist hat man auch nicht das
ganze mit der Pferdekutsche verglichen
und geschaut wo ist der der nächste
Stall wo ist das Auto unterbringen kann
meine persönliche Erfahrung ist wir
haben seit einem Jahr ein Auto
ja und auch das normale Auto das muss ja
auch nicht jeden Tag an die Ladesäule
also die konkrete Frage ist eigentlich
finden Sie auch das für das E-Auto
eigentlich ganz anders geworden werden
müsste im Rahmen der Veränderung unserer
Mobilität als es einfach nur als Ersatz
für den Verbrenner zu sehen
ist ein bisschen ein rhetorische Frage
aber ich nehme sie trotzdem gerne Schuld
Frau Kunkel
sondern es ist tatsächlich eigentlich
auch der Punkt dass ich sage die
Automobilindustrie macht ist in
Deutschland gar nicht wichtig sondern
sie müsste für das Fahrzeug eigentlich
ganz anders werden okay ich habe jetzt
habe ich sie besser verstanden vielen
Dank Frau Kunkel nickt auch schon heftig
müssen wir die Immobilität ganz anders
denken ja wir sind ja vor wir haben ja
das ist es ist schlecht da also Herr
Apfel sagt ja es ist nicht
konkurrenzfähig ist die schlechteste
Technologie z.B was was der was der Herr
jetzt eben sagt ich kann ja eben ich
muss nicht mehr zur Tankstelle fahren
ist doch z.B super kann man dafür werben
zu sagen ich kann einfach abends meinen
wenn ich eine Garage habe es gibt
übrigens 16 Millionen Einfamilienhäuser
in Deutschland ich glaube da gibt es
großes Potential wo Menschen einfach
nachts ihr Auto laden können und am
nächsten morgen ist es wieder voll eben
das Thema es muss nicht ständig ich
fahre nicht ständig an der Autobahn und
bin auf irgendeine teure
schnellladesäule angewiesen das sind
alles so Punkte die kommen ja in der
Lebensrealität der meisten Menschen gar
nicht vor und daher bin ich schon ist
der Meinung zu sagen man müsste vielmehr
die Vorteile rausstellen ich habe extra
nochmal nach Umfragen geschaut und ich
habe nur Umfragen gefunden unter E-Auto
Besitzern wo über 90 Prozent der
Befragten sagen sie würden nie wieder
zurück zum Verbrenner also die Menschen
die das gemacht haben sind
offensichtlich fast alle sehr happy
damit und sagen ich möchte gar nichts
anderes mehr fahren okay ich glaube hier
ist noch ein e-autofahrer in der Leitung
Herr katzikas aus Witzhelden hat sich
gemeldet hallo Herr Karl Ihre Frage ihre
Position bitte aber bitte um Kürze weil
wir nur noch paar Minuten haben ganz
kurz äh Fahrbericht ähm ich bin mit dem
ed vier mit der Familie nach Italien
gefahren hat alles wunderbar und ich
kann nur am Apple zustimmen fallen
schafften die Wolfsburg können Autos
baut was sie leider nicht bauen können
und das sehe ich als massive
Herausforderung Software das Navi ist
fünf mal ausgefallen weil viel Daten
verloren war nach Brenner war einfach
die Zielführung nicht möglich und ich
war wirklich neidisch ich komme wieder
auf der Rückfahrt Brenner und sie sehen
da 25 Ladestation für Tesla und zwei
mickrige für den Rest der Welt ich sehe
das so man muss die Verbrenner einfach
abschaffen alles auf elektrisch
umstellen und wir müssen das ist eine
wahnsinnige Möglichkeit für unsere
deutsche Industrie hier Innovation
hereinzubringen und wir sind die
Entwickler in allen technolog diesen
Bereichen und müssen das halt
Herausforderung nehmen und nicht so
klein klein sondern das ist die Zukunft
da wollen wir hin elektrische Energie
mit Möglichkeiten von Sonne Wind und die
Infrastruktur verstärken da sind
Potenziale die müssen gehoben werden und
Software Volkswagen da müsst ihr besser
werden
könnte sein dass derjenige den der
Gewinner ist der die der die gute
Infrastruktur hat ne tesla hat die sie
haben es gerade angesprochen sie kommen
darüber sehen 25 Ladestation
funktioniert auch noch ganz einfach in
Amerika übrigens steigen gerade alle
Hersteller auf den lade Infrastruktur
von den Ladestecker auf die Ladetechnik
von Tesla um das ist ein wirkliches
Zeichen was wir auch finde ich als
Alarmzeichen sehen müssten nur für die
deutsche Industrie und Tesla macht
übrigens gar keine Werbung jedenfalls
nicht in unserer Zeitung leider und hat
trotzdem eine riesen Fan Gemeinde und
die machen offenbar was richtig was die
anderen vielleicht sich auch noch
Abkommen können auch ganz gut kann ich
kann dazu alles ich kann den Kollegen
nur zustimmen alles was er gesagt hat
stimmt
[Gelächter]
auch eine schöne Sache danke Ihnen allen
für diese Runde auch fürs Presseclub
nachgefragt danke Ihnen für Ihre Anrufe
Ihre Fragen zum Thema das war der
Presseclub zum Thema verliert die
deutsche Autoindustrie den Anschluss an
die E-Mobilität danke ihnen fürs
zuschauen für Interesse fürs zu hören
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Sonntag
[Musik]